okay so here we are today I'm going to
try to peel a peach in a very
untraditional way on Twitter this person
from Japan uploaded a video of them
peeling a peach sort of taking their
thumbs and just opening up it's very
very sexual it's cool my friend Adam
challenged me to try and do it so let's
give it a go how hard can it be to peel
a peach some cult is just regular
blanching you put something in very very
hot water then you immediately put it in
cold water it gets it hot and then the
coldness loosens up the skin I'm very
inexperienced in the kitchen - I want to
point that out I don't know if I've ever
eaten this get a peach just raw who knew
peaches look like that the inside it
looks like they're using a white peach
if we can do a little comparison here
our white peach and then the yellow
peach a little different this slit is a
big giveaway that I think will make this
easier to peel apart evenly put three in
right now so according to the post it
says that the peaches are only supposed
to be in this hot water for 20 seconds
and then the cold water immediately
afterwards for five minutes let's do a
little light test just to see if like
lukewarm water is good enough to get it
going let that Blanche for a little bit
blanching beautiful let's get the full
experience here peeling this super
sexual peach for the internet so thumbs
nothing hard no so it's got to come to a
boil guys all right
I've wasted four peaches here to exploit
it I'm going to try and find ones that
sort of lend them to viewability
wow this one you get to blur this out
this is gonna get 88 on YouTube this is
too hot
okay wires at a boil 20 seconds guys
take them out in the water 5 minutes now
see this is the prism infuriating part
is the waiting
[Music]
all right oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what whoa whoa
so this one is closed I'm getting
somewhere like the skin is definitely
getting loose they didn't show this in
the bin tweet so how'd I mess that up
is that proper blanching let's google it
add salt to the water salt is adds and
waters because it increases the boiling
point of the water meaning your water
will have a higher temperature but so
it'll cook better let's get some salt
yeah let's drop this guy in there
got ya cooling down you can see the
little steam coming off it then five
minutes I'm gonna go peel from this end
I mean so not working didn't bummer man
the video there was like a line going
down it's like okay so they took this
knife here so I'm gonna be devastated
they pre sliced these things apparently
there's a way of doing this called
scoring
I mean you've cut a line already in the
peach and apparently that makes it
easier for the skin to come up because
water will get in so let's give that a
little try drop it in out of the water
here we go
dude are you for real like I'm mad I'm
gonna pause for now cuz that didn't work
I want to try riper peaches I think the
skin might be more ready to peel off
okay so we got bag of ripe peaches you
can just tell by the touch that it's
much different from any of the other
ones we had so I think the key is to
just have a very ripe peach dropping in
there blanch it pull it down all right
let's give it a go oh my god oh my god I
cannot believe this is happening
[Music]
I'm like mood right now
this is so great I'm like so happy Wow
getting emotional about this the thing
about where we started today there's
there's no way 20 or 40 perserverance
man i think the difference between ours
the japanese peach was a little less
ripe than ours because it held that nice
butt shape as it was peeled ours was
maybe a little too right but just ripe
enough that you can get that one
beautiful little peel I'm gonna go
surprise someone my little trick I just
learned here all right let's go this
impressing people what was it kind of
show you something cool what's gonna
happen boom look at that
look at that this [ __ ] oh yeah alright
wait now touch it go more dude that is
so weird
was the skin feel like oh that doesn't
feel good at all no it's actually tasty
take a bite of it I'll you I'll use him
with you I'll eat some with you all the
skins actually really good
the skins good like nature's prosciutto
[Music]
we did it well thanks guys yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]